Welcome back everyone this is going to be my
marvel falcon and winter soldier episode 4 video
john walker woke up and chose violence there
are so many easter eggs here obviously some
really big reveals so we'll break it all down if
you're brand new to the channel i'm doing videos
for all the episodes so be sure to subscribe
to get everything this is just the beginning
we're going to get loki episodes pretty soon after
this too careful for spoilers if you have not seen
the episode yet because we'll be talking about
everything i'll just start at the beginning of
the episode and we'll work our way through shot
by shot talking about easter eggs as we go along
the title of the episode was the world is watching
obviously a big reference to what happens at the
end of the episode with john walker killing that
flag smasher with the shield the very symbol that
that flag smasher character was talking about
earlier in the episode inspired him he was his
big captain america fanboy growing up so he was
literally killed by the thing that he looked up
to as a little kid how darkly ironic but i think
we all predicted this was the direction that dark
captain america was going john walker captain
america he was already in the process of losing
it it was just a question of when he was going
to fully lose it and i know you're all wondering
did he actually take that vial of super soldier
serum already it does seem like he did so i'll
talk about that more when we get to that part of
the video but the actual episode begins in wakanda
with a big flashback it's actually really cool i
wasn't expecting them to literally go to wakanda
in the episode so it was a really cool surprise
but you flash back to six years ago so this is
after they put him into cryo storage and
they've been deprogramming him working with him
but it's before the events of that black panther
post credit scene so he's still in the process
of trying to free himself from the hydra commands
he's working with Ayo around this campfire out in
the distance and she's going to activate him and
it's going to be this big test as to whether or
not his deprogramming has worked if he's been able
to beat it and it turns out that he does but that
is the connection between them in the past the
history that they share together so obviously that
brought them pretty close together that's a pretty
personal moment for bucky there there was the
scene at the end of episode 3 when she showed up
and it looked like there was some implied history
between them like they shared some connection that
went into the past so obviously this is them just
paying that off then we go back to present day
with Ayo yelling at bucky asking him why he freed
zemo what the hell dude why'd you do this she kind
of explains why it's so personal for them not only
did he kill king t'chaka she was chosen personally
by t'chaka to be part of his honor guard during
the summit so she failed at her task and she's
living with this great shame this whole time
and now zemo's running free so the shame is even
worse the way they explained that history i guess
king t'chaka didn't bring the entire dora milaje
with him to the events of captain america civil
war he left some of them back in wakanda like
these are just a couple of his special honor guard
from amongst the many dora milaje like later in
the episode we see the other door milaje show up
i'll talk about that too because that was probably
one of my favorite scenes from the episode but
there's only a couple of them we know there are
many dora milaje but this is why it's so personal
for Ayo why she hates zemo so much why she's
so hardcore about this it's not just that zemo
is number one on wakanda's hit list it's super
personal for her she winds up giving bucky eight
hours with zemo to try and get the flag smashers
then no matter what happens whether or not they're
successful they're coming for zemo that basically
takes them past that first big fight like okay
eight hours are up we're here to take him the way
zemo reacts to a lot of this to throughout the
episode is pretty funny he kind of tries to play
mind games with a lot of the different characters
including bucky including john walker captain
america even falcon he's a master manipulator
so of course he's going to be trying to work all
the characters throughout all the episodes but he
treats it like bucky is doing him a big favor like
they're bros oh thank you for saving me from the
door melange when falcon takes him to task about
killing nagel the way he plays it is kind of funny
too like he tries to play it off like he may not
have shot him when we all saw it happen this is
the way zemo is he's very slimy in that way then
when falcon starts talking about trying to find a
peaceful solution zemo tries to take them to task
over the flag smashers calling them supremacists
just like the nazis like don't look at her like
she's a little girl because she's not he draws the
comparison to the nazis to avengers age of ultron
the destruction of sokovia then tries to make the
comparison to the creation of the avengers as
if they're supremacists as well and that's where
bucky steps in like whoa whoa dude there is no
comparison between nazis and the avengers but if
you think about it zemo does hate the avengers so
of course he would see them the same way that he
sees all terrible people in the world zemo sort of
sets up the stakes for the next couple of episodes
saying that she's either going to wind up killing
you or you're going to wind up killing her it's
only going to escalate from here on which they
start to pay off at the end of the episode when
john walker captain america kills the flag smasher
he also implies that john walker is a supremacist
just because he says the whole idea of becoming
a superhuman cannot be separated from supremacist
ideals and the whole thing during the episode
is that john walker is obsessed with getting the
super soldier serum to his credit though zemo
does admit that steve rogers captain america
is the exception to his rule like what about steve
rogers oh okay there was one one really good super
soldier but then argues that there has never been
another person as inherently good as steve rogers
the way they frame the shot after this too of
falcon winter soldier and zemo against these
windows is obviously baked with a whole lot of
meaning as well because you have these giant
stained glass windows with stars i mean they're
stars of david but they're red white and blue
stars meant to evoke all this captain america
imagery with the light shining down on them also
a bit of a subtle reference to them being captain
america in the comics both of them have worn the
mantle of captain america in the comics before
then they go to that grc camp that we saw during
episode 3 where the flag smashers have been where
the donya madani character wound up dying zemo
explains a little of his history says that he used
to come here as a child a lot to attend parties
without really understanding the politics of the
day now in context of the episode based on his age
he's probably talking about cold war era politics
but i think it's also another subtle reference to
classic comic book zemo because he is running
around in his classic comic book costume that
version of the character was alive during world
war ii the politics of that day would have been
fascism in the nazis so Zemo's the only one who's
successful at getting information and he sort of
gets it out of this little girl with the turkish
delights like little secret between us don't tell
these guys over here they're bad people his whole
thing was he was trying to keep the information
from them for as long as possible so they wouldn't
just turn him over to the dora milaje when they
showed up but the really important scene that they
intercut with this is the flag smashers watching
the news coverage in that other scene of what
happened in the previous episode with the bombing
of that grc center the way the news broadcaster
talks about it is incredibly polarizing a bunch
of people hate the flag smashers even more now and
it's caused the grc to react by pushing through
even worse legislation worse for the refugees
but because it's polarizing people more it's also
brought way more followers to the flag smashers
so the violence begets more violence polarizes
more people makes things worse escalates things
and this is also to help set up the big twist at
the end of the episode which will continue to do
that john walker killing the flag smasher making
things escalate even more polarizing people even
more falcon's whole thing in this episode too is
that he's kind of trying to find a peaceful path
to this like this is only going to make things
worse and it all comes to pass everything does
get worse falcon does sympathize with Karli and
the people at the camp and he kind of explains
how things change for the worse since the snap
and the blip how after the snap everyone was
welcome everywhere just because people were
so busy trying to rebuild and now after the blip
with everyone back countries the grc are back to
their more xenophobic attitudes leaving a ton of
people homeless jobless just fighting for food so
the funny thing about the episode is if you take
their statements too literally out of context
it seems like they're saying that the blip was
kind of a bad thing when technically obviously
it was good bringing all those dead people back i
think a lot of the twists of the series in general
like their fundamental stance here that they're
taking with the flag smashers saying how things
are terrible for these people these refugees
everywhere depends on how much you believe that
that's what would really happen after the events
of avengers end game it's a very cynical take
on the mcu and i think there definitely would be
some countries around the world like third world
countries which commit human rights violations on
the regular anyway in the real world where things
would be this bad but in most of the world i don't
think that things would actually get this bad
falcon call sharon carter just reminding you
that she's helping them out on the sly using her
satellites tracking new captain america tracking
the flag smashers she also explains how things in
madrapur are about to erupt in war over the death
of nagel and the power broker is pissed she refers
to the power broker as a he like a male character
but that could just be misdirection she could be
withholding some information but then we find out
where the flag smashers have been hiding the 12
vials of super soldier serum it's in a grave
for this flag smasher character's grandfather
who fought during world war ii as a resistance
fighter fighting nazis just like steve rogers
captain america he explains his whole backstory
how he grew up being a captain america fanboy
what the symbol of the shield meant to him how the
world's more complicated now people need a leader
that looks like them that understands their
pain and obviously this is all foreshadowing
falcon becoming the next captain america because
this whole thing in the episode is understanding
other people's pain like he was a trauma
counselor for the military for a long time
he literally says this is completely my wheelhouse
they are in trauma right now i know how to talk to
these people but obviously this talk about him
loving captain america as a child is just to
foreshadow the dark captain america twist at the
end of the episode and when he says that karli
is just like steve rogers because she's a super
soldier like she's like a new version of captain
america it's also a subtle reference to the
female versions of captain america in the comics
there's been a couple like luke cage's daughter
with jessica jones eventually becomes an alternate
future version of captain america but if you guys
remember we have the marvel what if disney plus
series coming this year i will be doing videos for
all those episodes as well but they're going to be
doing an episode where peggy carter gets the super
soldier serum to become an alternate universe
version of captain america in that version
instead of getting the serum steve rogers winds
up becoming a world war ii version of iron man
only because peggy carter is part of the british
special forces they wind up calling her captain
britain which is also a big comic book character
even though he's a different comic book character
but it's just a fun meta twist on the concept
i love the way they imply she's just walking
around in broad daylight with a fanny pack full of
12 vials of super soldier serum then john walker
and battlestar barge in on bucky zemo and falcon
saying that they have to bring them in they want
to take zemo in themselves anyway and obviously
this is just foreshadowing john walker slowly
going crazier and crazier throughout the episode
they really wanted it to be obvious where he was
headed the funny thing about this whole situation
too is that even his partner battle star comes
around on falcon's idea like oh hold on let's let
falcon try this let's see where it goes he might
be able to win them over then even though walker
winds up chaining zemo to the boiler immobilizing
him he winds up escaping later just setting up the
big twist with the super soldier serum don't
worry we'll talk about that in a second too
zemo definitely notices how crazy walker is going
so i'm expecting him to try and manipulate him
in future episodes the same way he manipulates
bucky's ptsd to try and get him to do things the
flag smashers have their funeral for donya madani
then she has her talk with falcon in the funny
thing about this dude like you know he starts to
win her over slowly they find some common ground
but they really want her to come off like the
other side of this john walker captain america
coin so he's sort of like this hard-liner hardcore
dude who's just going to steamroll everyone the
way falcon kind of talks circles around her makes
her seem just like the opposite side of that
coin like she's the edgy teenager that's taking
everything out of context she's not really seeing
the actual big picture even though she thinks she
is her violence will only be get more violence
making things worse polarizing people even more
she claims everyone's being kicked out of their
homes but think about it this way way back during
spider-man far from home aunt may said that when
she got blit back she reappeared inside her and
peter's old apartment in queens and because it's
five years later another family had been living
there the whole time they treated it kind of as
a joke during the movie like the wife of the new
family thought that she was her husband's mistress
and some of them thought that she was a ghost but
spider-man and aunt may didn't turn around and
kick that new family out of their old department
they just went and found the new home somewhere
else in queens so like i said the whole premise
of the grc during the series the idea that they're
funneling people into these camps and people
are getting really xenophobic it depends on
how much you think this would actually happen
after avengers end game and just for a timeline
reference the events of falcon and winter soldier
what we're seeing unfold right now take place
before the events of spider-man far from home
this is around six months after avengers end game
spider-man far from home is closer to eight months
after avengers end game i love the way they played
john walker during this scene too while this is
all unfolding you see all those nervous tics that
he has like you just wait for him to explode they
foreshadow him taking the super soldier serum when
he talks to bucky must be easy for you having the
super soldier serum but he thinks that things will
be easy for him if he gets the serum which he then
later does during the episode then as expected he
barges in makes a mess of things spirals out
of control zemo escapes out of his cuffs as
you would expect him to but manages to chase down
karli and destroy all the remaining super soldier
serum vials with the exception of one which john
walker capped notices after he knocks out zemo
with the shield look at how thirsty he is for that
super soldier serum everyone post all the memes of
course he pockets it and doesn't tell the others
when they show up he doesn't even tell his partner
battlestar right after this two karli's partner
sort of reiterates the idea all the vials were
destroyed because they don't know that john walker
stole that one vial even though they're making it
seem like there is no more serum left in the world
you have to remember thunderbolt raw still has his
batch 6 version 2 from the weapons plus program so
technically there is more super soldier serum out
there and there's other potential nations like the
russians could possibly have some version of it
then they get a text from the power broker who
claims they're going to kill all the flag smashers
if they don't turn over the serum which of course
they can't now just hyping up more conflict later
with a big power broker reveal we all knew this
was going to happen it was just a question of
when they were going to finally reveal the power
broker which might wind up being during episode
5 but then they make their plan to separate all
the characters so that they can kill the new dark
captain america zemo has this big conversation
with falcon about whether or not he would have
taken the super soldier serum had the
military offered it to him he says no
without any hesitation and i do believe him even
zemo is impressed like damn and i think that's
all in service of setting up the idea that when
he eventually does take up the mantle of captain
america by the end of the series why he would then
not get the super soldier serum i've gotten a lot
of questions about this in the past like right
after they announced the series and i'd always
assumed that he wouldn't just because that's the
way they played in the comics but also that's kind
of the way they've set up mcu falcon especially
in the first episode he literally says my only
superpower is that i believe we can do better so
does that sound like a person who would then just
turn around and juice the minute he gets his eyes
on that sweet honey not like john walker captain
america licking his lips there love the way
that bucky also talks about john walker as well
something's not right with that dude crazy knows
crazy i know when i see it because i'm crazy too
then right on cue walker busts in ordering them
to turn zemo over to the us military and starts
a fight with falcon or tries to start a fight
with him going full dude bro like is this a bar
fight is this spring break it really does seem
like he's about to throw a fist until he stopped
dead in his tracks by the door melange who roll in
and proceed to humiliate him in the best possible
way just kicking the crap out of him in the span
of a couple minutes it's hilarious watching him
flounder trying to fight them he never had a
chance they've come for zemo so obviously he
should be worried but it seems like he's actually
more excited to watch them beat the crap out of
john walker like he pulls up a chair like oh
this is gonna get good bucky does try to jump
in stopping Ayo when it seems like she's going to
kill john walker even though i don't think that
she was actually going to kill him love the way
they pin the shield to the table too and he just
flounders there john walker trying to yank it free
for the next couple of minutes Ayo then shows off
some hardcore ninja moves to deactivate bucky's
vibranium arm causing it to fall right off of his
body what she's doing here is just hitting some
special pressure points where the vibranium arm
meets his body at the joint so obviously the dora
milaje would have some secret moves for disabling
vibranium technology zemo of course yeets out el
chapo style loved the reference from falcon huh
didn't think he would pull an el chapo what he's
referencing is that el chapo used a secret tunnel
to escape authorities and zemo basically jumped
into the sewers it looks like the way they end
the fight is hilarious too this other door milajit
just yanks her vibranium spear out releasing the
shield like it's no big deal after watching john
walker struggle with it for minutes she does the
classic captain america shield stop move with him
just sitting there all dejected and defeated like
damn and it almost seems like she's doing to walk
off with it like they're going to take the shield
back to wakanda with them because technically the
vibranium was stolen from wakanda until ayo tells
her to leave it and hands it back to walker like
she's giving a child back his toy like here you go
go on your way go have some fun when bucky
reattaches his arm we get a better look at the
technology too how it connects to his body he's
got special vibranium piece attached directly to
his shoulder joint where the arm attaches so you
can hear at home with energy when he activates it
when john walker says they weren't even super
soldiers like he's so depressed that he got
his ass handed to him so badly what he might not
necessarily understand maybe he doesn't completely
know what's going on with the dora milaje is
that they're meant to be the most fearsome
hardcore fighters on the planet next to groups
like the avengers people with actual superpowers
armed with the most advanced tech on
the planet and the best fighting skills
so if they wanted to the dora milaje would be able
to steamroll the flag smashers in no time flat but
obviously because they see this is a problem for
the rest of the world not a problem for wakanda
they don't care about what karli morgenthau is
doing we don't see them again in the episode you
have to remember too talking more about black
panther talking about the wakanda flashbacks
black panther is still alive during this point in
the timeline even though chadwick boseman may he
rest in peace passed away last year remember this
is only a couple months after avengers end game
so it would have been black panther to send them
send the door milage Ayo these other characters
to go take zemo into custody and bring him back to
wakanda to face their justice but then john walker
and battlestar talk about taking the super soldier
serum battlestar making a callback to the first
captain america movie the idea that the serum only
makes you more of what you already are and then
thinking more about steve rogers being amazing
but you also have to remember on the same side
of that coin red skull was a metaphorical monster
he took the serum and it turned him into a literal
looking monster same thing with the abomination
during incredible hulk the whole idea that trying
to foreshadow john walker kind of an animal a
rage monster is slowly going to go over the edge
and become even more so once he takes the serum
karli calls falcon's sister to bond over hating
new dark captain america john walker pretty much
everybody's on board with that i feel like that's
common ground for most fans right now then later
when they actually meet up she reiterates the idea
that they are going to kill john walker captain
america sharon carter chiming back in reminding
you that she's actually participating in the
episode tracking john walker on her satellite and
that's obviously when things go crazy the flag
smashers capture battle star hold him hostage
while walker searched for him this was part of
their plan to separate them so it'd be easier
to kill john walker potentially but here's the
really important thing when he's actually taking
out this flag smasher you see john walker bend
that metal pipe and the flag smasher says oh
crap it's because he's realized that john walker
has probably taken the serum or has the serum
at least that's what they're implying like
john walker wouldn't be able to bend this
giant metal pipe if he was just a normal person
but based on the rest of the way he fights in the
episode it doesn't seem like he totally has
the serum so maybe he just took it and it's
taking a while for it to work its magic inside his
bloodstream like it hasn't reached 100 in his body
remember the new batch of serum is different
from the classic steve rogers version because
you don't need vitarase to bombard your body to
actually activate it in your bloodstream you just
inject yourself like you would give yourself any
kind of shot i did love john walker's funny line
where he's like what's with all the knives the
whole thing with that is the stunt coordinator
said that they were actually consciously trying
to use fewer guns during the series and i think
part of the reason for that was so that they could
do more hand-to-hand combat fight scenes just to
make the fights seem more dynamic most of these
fight scenes are all pretty fantastic i feel like
the stunt work on falcon winter soldier has been
pretty good very much inspired by the fight scenes
during the winter soldier movie but they get john
walker captain america in a full grapple hold and
they have him dead to rides karli launches at him
with the knife to kill him and he's only saved by
battlestar who jumps in her path but that's not
actually what kills him taking the knife it's
actually karli kicking him into the stone pillar
so hard that his body just folds under the impact
then i really love the editing during this scene
the sound kind of cuts out a little bit as you
take john walker's perspective and he slowly loses
it predictably i mean we all knew this was going
to happen eventually he chases down karli's friend
the other flag smasher who was the captain america
fanboy killing him with the shield in broad
daylight with a whole crowd of people recording it
on their phones you have to imagine that all these
people are uploading this to every single social
media platform all the footage to youtube facebook
instagram and within minutes is going to be spread
all over the world everybody's going to see this
so quite literally the whole world is watching
it's a little bit like spider-man far from home
and the idea of mysterio's fake video trying to
dox spider-man and frame him for his death like
j jonah jameson posts this footage on his news
website the daily bugle which is a website instead
of a newspaper now but then from there you have to
imagine that people all over the world would be
re-uploading and sharing the footage all over
the place youtube facebook everywhere but the
big takeaway here heading into episode 5 is how
the us military and john walker himself are going
to respond to this pr nightmare inevitably in how
this is going to polarize more people like they
foreshadowed earlier in the episode causing more
to flock to the flag smashers cause supporting
them making things escalate even more as zemo
predicted also they do need to confirm next week
whether or not john walker really did take the
serum as they kind of implied he did during this
episode in finally revealing who the power broker
really is even though that kind of seems like a
c plot now like it actually seems like the least
interesting part of the episode but everybody post
all your theories in the comments below do you
think because of him bending this metal pipe that
john walker has already jacked himself up with
that vial of super soldier serum and who do you
think the power broker is i'll be doing another
bonus video next so just leave all your requests
in the comments below or big questions you want me
to include in that while you wait for everything
everyone click here for that brand new marvel
loki trailer in easter eggs and click here for
all my falcon and winter soldier episode videos
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!